de commencer cette audition mes chers
collègues monsieur le Président nous ont
tendance ce matin Serge les Jimmy
président de la collectivité
territoriale de Martinique dans le cadre
de la préparation de notre rapport sur
l'évolution institutionnelle des
Outre-mer nous vous remercions vivement
monsieur le Président représente nous
sommes en train d'achever notre cycle
d'audition que nous a permis de
consulter les exécutifs de
Saint-Barthélémy la Réunion
Wallis-et-Futuna Saint-Martin
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon la Polynésie
française la Guyane Mayotte et la
Guadeloupe vous êtes à l'origine de
l'appel de Fort-de-France lancé le 17
mai dernier qui a marqué le paysage
politique de ces derniers mois au point
que le Président de la République de 7
septembre dernier le chantier dit de la
refondation des politiques dont les
outre-mer nous sommes évidemment très
intéressés par le diagnostic de mal
développement structurels que vous
portez sur la situation dans votre
territoire est plus largement sur celle
dans nos outre-mer vous pourrez nous
préciser bien évidemment aussi des
suites donnés par le gouvernement et le
chef de l'État à l'appel de
Fort-de-France nous savons aussi que des
travaux sont en cours au congrès des
élus de la Martinique et vous me direz
également quels sont les premières
pistes institutionnelles qui sont
dégagent je vais donc vous donner la
parole monsieur le Président pour un
exposé liminaire sur la base du
questionnaire qui vous a été adressé au
préalable pour préparer cette audition
et je vous interrogerai ensuite en
qualité de cours rapporteur avec
Micheline Jacques également co
rapporteur et puis les collègues qui
souhaiteront vous interpeller et en
savoir un peu plus monsieur présent vous
avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame
je retrouve des visages connus très
connus bien connu
ici et c'est une occasion pour moi de
vous donner à la fois mon sentiment
à la fois personnel parce que je pense
qu'il faut bien indiquer que mes
convictions personnelles sont présentes
même si nous avons dans le cadre que
nous avons défini la responsabilité et
l'obligation de respect de la pluralité
des positions en Martinique ou en Guyane
ou Guadeloupe etc
je voudrais saluer le travail du Sénat
parce que j'ai lu avec attention les le
dernier rapport mais celui aussi de Ma
Grâce auparavant
je jalousais toujours le Sénat je disais
à l'Assemblée nationale n'aurait pas de
moyens aussi importants mis à
disposition des groupes pour nous
permettre d'avoir des rapports aussi de
très grande qualité je trouve que les
rapports du cinéma c'est vraiment pas
une flatterie d'introduction et c'est de
très grande qualité et j'ai lu aussi le
rapport sur la partie maritime
j'ai tout lu et j'attendais à un moment
donné que c'est toi qui a pris l'idée
c'est pas là qu'à mon avis tu abordes la
dimension service écologique rendu par
l'outre-mer au monde à la France et à
l'Europe bon j'ai pas vu ça de danse ça
m'a un petit peu froissé donc
on a décidé de continuer le combat à
Martinique parce que le service
écologique rendu par ces pays c'est pas
seulement de la côté c'est pas de
l'esthétique c'est pas que du loisir
c'est pas parce qu'il en met et puis de
l'eau et puis coco c'est pas ça du tout
en français ça veut dire il y a de l'eau
de la mer c'est beau c'est vraiment une
richesse écologique et dans le monde qui
se présente à nous ça va être une valeur
ajoutée exceptionnelle de stabilisation
du monde tant sur le plan écologique et
économique maritime aussi de la paix et
c'est très important alors vous vous
avez me demander de répondre à quelques
questions
j'y vais franchement
en créole il y a une expression est très
intéressante qui dit nous bute
cette Catherine pourrait traduire ça
très très bien je pense et c'est un mot
deux mots très important nous
c'est petit je pense que quand je dis
nous c'est nous c'est pas Martinique
isolée c'est y compris Mayotte et qu'on
peut tout le monde
on est arrivé vers le système je pense
qu'il faut vraiment marquer ça
clairement
on est d'ailleurs au bout d'un système
qui risque de nous conduire face à des
murs et franchissables et pire que les
murs et franchissable qui continue à
exister c'est surtout des gouffres qui
peuvent qui risquent de nous emporter
tous dans une relation hybride
incompris dans un contexte historique
identitaire compliqué difficile où on
avoir un besoin de respirer d'énergie
tout en étant dans une république qui
reste qu'on le veuille ou non assez
conservatrice dans ses principes et de
son organisation même malgré des
évolutions que capacité dans un petit
moment donc on est arrivé au bout d'un
système c'est pas que le système
statutaire parce que je vois qu'on
plante le déco sur l'évolution
statutaire je pense que la
mondialisation un petit peu redéfinie et
les conceptions classiques de l'année
pendant l'autonomie de la départementale
des gestion de la région ça a l'ami tout
ça en terme de dogme juridique donc dès
que vous demandez un juriste de parler
politique je commence à fuir parce que
c'est Camille Darcy avait disait ça
célèbre député il est plus mauvais
politiques c'est son éguristes parce que
excusez-moi pour les juristes qui sont
un peu Bizet mais parce que ils ont
tendance mais quand il y a des
politiques qui font du juridisme ça
commence à s'améliorer d'ailleurs pour
ça que c'est engageant politique bon on
pourrait dire que ce sont les meilleurs
politiques ce sont les poètes ça
s'adressait à 16h quoi mais bon ça et je
pense que on est arrivé au bout d'un
système beaucoup économique social
culturelle relationnel gouvernance
démocratie on est arrivé au bout et
d'ailleurs le résultat que nous avons eu
aux élections en Martinique je parle que
de la Martinique c'était la dernière
fois avec l'élection présidentielle à un
sens extrêmement précis c'est que nous
sommes pas seulement entrés dans une
assimilation aliénation qui qui va nous
perdre on est tombé il y a une chute de
la conscience politique collective qui
est créée par un système qui donne le
sentiment de pouvoir tout faire mais à
patrie et en même temps qui a des
attitudes et des postures de gouvernance
étiquet voire fraternaliste voir
paternaliste et même condescendante d'un
état sur le plan local qui structure les
choses à sa manière et qui nie les
réalités locales locales les identités
ça dépend des individus il y a des
individus qui font pas ça du tout je
parle des organisations gouvernance
d'État locales il y en a qui ont
comportement qui démontre bien que des
pré carré du système passé que demeure
même dans ses principes nous sommes au
bout aussi parce que sur le plan
économique il nous faut sortir des des
économies un petit peu distanciers de
comptoir
d'importation massive de consommation
massive
on peut il faut absolument reprendre la
main sur les résiliens sociales et
économiques par la construction de
nouveaux modèles économiques et si on
veut construire les nouveaux modèles
économique différencier certainement
d'un pays à l'autre il faut reprendre la
main sur ce qu'on appelle le droit à
l'initiative et ce droit à l'initiative
je défie un juriste me démontrer que
j'ai un vrai droit initiative
si on me transcrit pas dans le binaire
73 74 on me met dans cette espèce de
double balancement le droit à
l'initiative à mon avis est très
important c'est à dire la
co-construction de politique publique
avec des tables parce que nous sommes
dans une république mais localement et
notamment aller vers plus de pouvoir
normatif
quand je dis pouvoir le motif je parle
pas de compétences parce que je le dis
au Sénat il y a beaucoup de juristes
d'ailleurs en Martinique je veux pas
parler utopique qui font une confusion
intellectuelle assez incroyable entre
compétences et pouvoir bon quand on a
des compétences on a des compétences on
n'a pas le pouvoir de l'initiative ni
réglementaire nous savons les processus
je les connais parfaitement malgré les
évolutions on est arrivé au bout d'un
système aussi en termes de
particularisme reconnu à la fois par
l'Europe par l'article 348
par la France dans l'article 73 qui a
été modifié successivement et depuis 46
158 en 2003 plus particulièrement et en
2008 qui a donné des évolutions de la
rédaction de l'artiste 73 nous avons eu
ces enjeux là et il nous faut absolument
que la
l'ouverture dans nos espaces maritimes
soit une vraie réalité et ne pas
considérer que le seul tubulaire qui
existe et la relation entre Paris et
Martinique et qu'on peut parfaitement
être dans la République tout en étant à
responsabilité capable de signer des
accords avec des pays qui sont à côté
moi je parle ça d'une nouvelle
diplomatie territoriale économique quand
je parle diplomaticité je parle pas de
coopération la coopération existant soit
je parle de diplomatie territoire
économique nous sommes bien sûr je
pourrais développer ça tout à l'heure si
vous me posez des questions ce qui passe
par des connectibilités culturelles
identitaires infrastructurelle maritime
numérique etc qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui et je suis bien placé vous
le dire je veux une sortie d'une
discussion avec ça ad sur les ports on
voit parfaitement que la connectivité
infrar régionale
est assez réduite par rapport à la
dynamique de la connectivité maritime
simplement parce qu'on était abusé à
exporter la banane du rhum et Cannes etc
mais on est resté le même principe ce
qui exporte des tonnes de bananes je
suis pas contre la banane au Congrès je
pense que la banane il faut continuer à
l'exporter se battre pour la banane
propre le romancier mais il y a pas que
ça et puis nous sommes dans une
dynamique qui qui nécessite une
cohérence de politique de développement
par rapport au secteur de
géographique de l'île nous sommes aussi
au début
j'insiste monsieur le Président d'une
prise de conscience de nos richesses
géostratégiques et le jour la Martinique
la Guyane la Réunion Mayotte etc vont
vraiment pleinement prendre conscience
au-delà de la richesse écologique que
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure le service
écologique rendu compte puis carbone par
nos pays
richesse écologique on puis carbone de
nos pays assurant la stabilité il y a
une position géostratégique de chaque
pays d'outre-mer qui fait que la France
c'est le seul pays où le de ce que
jamais ah ça c'est une phrase
pittoresque mais c'est pas que bitoris
ça a un sens politique majeur et de ce
fait nous ne profitons pas de nos
positions géostratégiques de chaque pays
on profite pas de ça on va pas qu'on me
dise quoi que ce soit on ne profite pas
de ces dynamiques là simplement parce
que la
on va aborder un peu la partie
européenne rapidement sur les ce qu'on
appelle le développement intégré interne
des pas suffisamment prise sous son sens
géostratégique vous imaginez monsieur le
Président que vous allez acheter une des
matières premières à Bordeaux à Nantes
je sais pas où pour traiter ou peut-être
au nord de l'Europe à reykjaviko ça
c'est pour l'essence et vous allez
découvrir en fait que le matière
première que vous avez importé vient du
Brésil
alors la matière première sort du Brésil
notamment du paras va en France est
transformée ou pas même boot c'est le
cas du Gohan a un jour le buvait un goût
du goûté
ça a été transformé
j'étais dans un
comment dire
j'ai option en train de boire qui est
fait à Ivry alors que le Brésil était à
côté c'est le produit qui est à côté je
vous raconte ces absurdités pour dire on
est vraiment arrivé à des limites
nous sommes
arrivés à des limites sur les richesses
qui sont essentielles notamment la
biodiversité vous savez 80% la
biodiversité la France est outre-mer où
on n'est pas rentré dans un processus de
filière nouvelle nous permettant de
sortir du pré carré des deux ou trois
exportations je pense que là on peut
tirer des richesses et des profils
bonjour vous pouvez prendre 50 000
exemples sur le plan économique pour
dire qu'on est arrivé nous sommes
arrivés aussi au bout de réforme sur des
réformes je pense que le moment est venu
et 46 a été une consécration très
importante du droit à l'égalité pour
sortir
des systèmes de gouverneur pour aller
vite des arrêtés qui étaient pris à
l'encontre des lois qui était votées ici
donc 46 c'est un pas 58 un peu modifié
les choses mais pas trop c'est surtout
2003 on a vraiment la mise en place d'un
système à la carte des statuts donc on a
une évolution de la différenciation une
évolution de la diversité des actions ce
qui fait aujourd'hui pratiquement les
douze pays où les parlementaires ont
pratiquement chacun un statut un peu
différencié pour prendre un exemple très
précis le statut actuel de la Martine
n'est pas le statut de la Guadeloupe
le statut de la Guyane n'est pas le
statut à une institué donc on a un
processus qui a été enclenché là il faut
saluer Jacques Chirac qui a initié ce
processus là dès la loom c'était pas lui
c'était que Mitterrand et mais après il
a transformé ça dans la dans la
modification considérale de 2003 et
c'est confortable en 2008 et nous avons
un processus qui est engagé qui nous
permet d'avoir un article beaucoup plus
amélioré mais c'est une amélioration et
là j'aborde la dimension purement
juridique c'est une amélioration à la
contrainte et au corset je parle de la
673 de la Constitution après je parlais
pour la France pour conclure de l'appel
de fourgon l'article 73 donne deux
respirations
quand je dis respiration vous avez par
rapport à ce que je dis tout à l'heure
vous comprenez bien la dimension que la
première respiration c'est que ça permet
à une collectivité territoriale de
pouvoir adapter non ça permet à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat d'adapter ou de
modifier des textes
et voilà le jour mais j'ai fait 15 ans
je peux vous dire que chaque fois que
j'ai vu arriver sur des ordonnances
directement c'est pas si c'est la
modalités juridique la plus précieuse
qui existe au monde pour pouvoir adapter
à chez nous on fait dans un coin qui est
plus gouvernemental qu'autre chose et
quand il y a adaptation des conditions
sont réunies de la rapidité du texte
qu'il faut absolument mettre un petit
amendement parce qu'on s'est battu ça
mangeable j'ai toujours appelé ça à
l'assemblée des des amendements
ensoleillement quoi on te donne il y a
pas il y avait un pas d'analyses en
profondeur seulement quand il y a un
texte sur le commerce on peut aller plus
loin donc cette possibilité d'adaptation
est une responsabilité de l'Assemblée
nationale par localement
maintenant on peut aussi aller plus loin
en disant bon on vous donne la
possibilité aussi par des habilitations
de pouvoir
et fait et faire des adaptations y
compris dicter la loi sauf la réunion
qui a pas voulu faire ce genre de choses
là c'est
la possibilité d'habiter de l'animer à 3
de du texte et c'est aliné à toi dit
quoi
vous pouvez demander une habilitation
moi je l'ai expérimenté
je vous donne mon expérience 3 ans
bon pour l'avoir pour la voir j'ai
plutôt raison
j'ai eu
une habilitation en énergie en formation
professionnelle et bien on transporte
j'ai eu des habilitations attention
c'était pas la thématique
c'était pas la thématique transport
c'était un habilitation par thème à
l'intérieur du transport
non mais franchement comment construit
la loi comme ça et pareil pour la partie
énergie chaque fois que vous abordez le
sujet vous avez une habilitation que
vous êtes à coller dans la même
habilitation d'ailleurs on étudie chaque
point à quel moment vous assurez le une
initiative ou une pensée tu vas bien
transversale et d'avoir une conception
globale d'une politique de l'énergie si
on vous donne pas une habilitation qui
soit globale et transversale sont sur ne
serait-ce que ça c'est pas le cas et
j'ai mené les négociations moi-même dans
tous les ministères pour savoir
exactement ce que je pouvais obtenir et
bien ça a dû c'est pour ça que ça dure 3
ans parce qu'il fallait faire des
allers-retours avec les ministres oui je
prends un exemple extrêmement précis
j'avais la méditation pour faire une
unité de transport au lieu de 17
il fallait que j'ai une habilitation
pour pouvoir créer Martini transport ok
je l'ai eu au bout de trois ans mais
attention je voulais quand même aborder
la question du ressources parce que vous
pouvez pas avoir une structure si vous
n'avez pas d'argent donc j'ai abordé ce
qu'on appelle le VT j'aborde le VT il a
fallu bien sûr six mois de négociation
de discussion pour obtenir que je puisse
intervenir sur le VT bon et j'ai obtenu
une panne deuxième habitation mais une
autorisation déterminée aux yeux bon
rendez compte c'est incroyable donc
monsieur le Président habilitation c'est
vraiment pas la solution même amélioré
par l'État tel que Manuel Macron voulait
faire ça en 2018 de mémoire ou 2019 où
il avait il devait le faire puisque il
n'y avait pas eu
l'équilibre politique qu'il fallait
aussi au Congrès mais son idée de dire
mais on va pas habilité par les
l'assemblée mais on va habiter
directement l'exécutif je trouve pas que
ce soit une bonne solution c'est pour ça
que je suis personnellement
convaincu qu'on est au bout d'une
possibilité et d'adaptation par
nous-mêmes par la voie de la méditation
puisque la durée de mandat est alignée
sous la durée du mandat et c'est celui
qui arrive à 6 mois ou un an pour voir
renouveler l'habilitation qui est en
cours bon c'est vraiment du bricolage je
me permets de le dire sans insulte
vis-à-vis de qui que ce soit mais c'est
vraiment du bricolage qu'est-ce que ça
peut
pourraient donner
si on est au bout du système que
pourrait-on faire pour pouvoir
installer en Martinique en Guadeloupe
ailleurs de ceux qui veulent la
possibilité d'assumer un droit
d'initiative locale sans remettre en
cause le droit à l'égalité moi j'ai une
phrase que j'en passe souvent je dis le
droit à l'égalité n'est pas l'ennemi du
doigt la différence on peut absolument
pas la différenciation des politiques
publiques obtenir
des stratégies de développement qui
soient propres à la Guadeloupe propre à
la Martinique propre à la Guyane ça me
semble essentiel d'aller beaucoup plus
loin
avant d'aborder la France encore et la
question de la différenciation je pense
que la question des différenciation a
été malabordée dans les textes qui sont
qui sont passés c'est plutôt une
différenciation et des aspects
intéressants dedans mais il y a quand
même une état d'esprit de la
différenciation qui a différenciation
entre régions c'est-à-dire cette région
peut prendre des responsabilités en
termes de compétences d'expérimentation
sur l'éducation suit la prévention
d'énergie moi je vois pas ça comme ça
moi je pense que la différenciation
c'est la capacité qu'on donne aux
différentes régions y compris en France
parce que j'ai signé des deux mails le
livre blanc des régions de France si
vous avez lu qui demande des politiques
de différenciation voir d'autonomie même
le terme est employé par les présidents
les présidents de Jean de France donc
mettre le chapeau sur la Martinique ou
d'autres pays qui demandent un vrai
autonomie mais je pense franchement
qu'il faut absolument aller vers ces
différenciation en installant dans
chaque région qui le souhaite sur la
base de curseur la possibilité
d'installer des pouvoirs normatifs
c'est-à-dire de pouvoir d'adapter la loi
et le règlement et des possibilités sur
des thématiques qui sont bien bordées de
pouvoir
initier la loi parce qu'il faut pas
perdre aujourd'hui on peut initier la
loi par la méditation il faut pas qu'on
ait que l'adaptation et qu'on n'est pas
l'initiation de la loi et c'est très
important pour nous de garder les deux
éléments de
l'habilitation de le transférer dans un
pouvoir accorder pas un pouvoir ponctuel
avoir continué
continue bien bordé avec bien sûr tous
les processus de contrôle de conseil
d'État est qu'on peut imaginer et y
compris j'ai vu dans certains rapports
que certains jeux ils disaient pour
quelle raison nous pouvons pas avoir des
mécanismes de contrôle des assemblées
qui chaque année pour avoir une réunion
de contrôle au de la même du contrôle et
fait par l'État local ou des comptes etc
aux chambériens des comptes qu'on pourra
voir que l'assemblée qui montre bien que
le curseur de l'autonomie petite
autonomie petite différenciation grande
autonomie et sous la responsabilité de
chaque assemblée et notre assemblée
Martinique peut parfaitement voter un
curseur de cette taille-là maximum
d'aller sur la Guyane ou la Guadeloupe
peut proposer autre chose voilà pour ce
que je souhaitais dire en préambule par
rapport à vos interesses pour terminer
c'est sur l'Apple
France est je dis ça et qui est très
souvent c'est véritablement écrit
le vote au présidentiel m'a beaucoup
marqué et ensuite
j'ai vu mon pays
décliné je vois mon pays décliné encore
plus de Guinée au cours des cinq
dernières années nous sommes passés à
-35 à -40000 habitants en à peine 10 ans
la Martinique qui avait 400 000
habitants un peu près va se retrouver à
250 000 habitants si on fait rire sinon
200000 c'est pas possible de spectateurs
de ce genre de choses là alors les
raisons pas le temps de les multiplier
mais vous connaissez parfaitement mal
développement
structurel inégalité puissante 80000
personnes sur le pauvreté enfin bref et
40% des jeunes c'est au chômage ces
indicateurs tout le monde les connaît
quelle est la réaction par rapport à
cette situation un prêt carré de système
économique qui n'a pas bougé depuis 60
ans dans ces mécanismes une absence de
démocratie économique vrai je pour que
j'assume ce que je veux dire une absence
de démocratie une présence de l'égalité
des droits qui au compte-goutte de la
part de l'État souvent avec une une
espèce de sentiment
d'assistanat et de kemon qui est devenu
insupportable et on ne plus en plus
étranger un autre géographie à notre
culture un autre identité et ces
derniers temps nous avons vécu quelques
expériences dures d'un État qui
considérait pas les collectivités de
Martinique y compris par le monter y
compris élu comme des gens qui sont
capables de pouvoir assumer des gaspects
attribuer toute espèce de raison de
cause sur l'ingénierie qui n'existe pas
dans les pays mais ça me semble donc
c'est ta peste un vrai cri en disant
attention il nous faut changer le mode
de relation avec l'État mais il nous
faut changer le monde de relation de
nous-même avec nous-mêmes c'est-à-dire
c'est pas seulement
de dire qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait mettre
en place pour construire un processus
cet appel a été rédigé lors d'une
réunion des régions handicap
périphériques a été signée par
l'ensemble des présidents présents ce
président j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus
les présidents qui ont la présidente
à qui que ce soit pour parlons leur nom
donc je parle au nom parce que je les
respecte beaucoup de la réunion de la
Guyane de Mayotte Excel deuxième chose
c'est que les signataires bien sûr ont
des
enjeux historiques politiques qui leur
sont propres
vous imaginez bien que Mayotte n'a
jamais pris
l'arrêt de quoi la ligne
autonomiste pour voir signer ça je le
dis devant toi pour qu'il y ait pas
d'ambiguïté et qu'on ne fasse pas de
l'intention de cette nature à qui que ce
soit bon
je prends un autre exemple que Gabriel
servile et la Guyane avaient leur propre
trajet 3 politiques historique et
économique avec des demandes qui sont
extrêmement claires et la Guadeloupe
n'en parlons pas on des postures et des
positions claires avec les deux
présidents parce que c'est le seul
endroit on a pas la Réunion c'est le cas
on a deux présidents donc on est dans ce
qu'on appelle une pluralité de
positionnement qui montre bien que les
évolutions récentes constitutionnelles
autour des pays d'entre eux-mêmes ils
n'étaient pas inutiles et surtout est
inspiré par des besoins vitaux ce qui
s'est passé au cours des 30 dernières
années et ceux qui se passe aujourd'hui
ce sont besoin vital de voir
reconstruire quelque chose qui puisse
nous donner plus de place à au
développement local à l'ingénierie
locale etc troisième chose c'est que
nous avons un socle commun de
signataires de l'appel de Fort-de-France
qui est pas de statu quo c'est ça le
Souka on ne veut pas de statu quo
maintenant quel est le trajectoire qui a
été dessiné on verra pour chaque pays je
sais que nous avons une réunion à
Bruxelles il y a pendant trois jours on
a fait une nouvelle réunion c'est
exactement tout ce que les gens
indiquent clairement bon chacun à sa
trajectoire nous avons rencontré le
président de la République et je tiens à
le remercier parce que il a réagi assez
vite puisque on a fait la déclaration
mais juin on s'est vu le 7 septembre La
Réunion est tout le monde était présent
à mon avis a permis d'ouvrir les
perspectives
à l'initiative et qui est liée à
l'initiative de la Belle Époque donc je
veux dire ici que il n'est pas question
que l'État préempte l'initiative des
élus de la Martinique de Mayotte etc
nous voulons bien sûr travailler très
clairement l'état en toute transparence
il y a pas de problème mais que l'État
ne préample pas si ce genre
d'infantilisation ce genre de
d'aboutissement de l'idée de la pensée
qui tue et qui Allienne les gens il faut
laisser les élus qui ont pris une
initiative politique de mener le combat
politique et à ce moment on va négocier
avec l'État point par point et nous
avons mis deux trains en marche pour la
Martinique je ne parle pas des autres et
que je respecte beaucoup on a mis un
train en marche la réalité locale où on
est on en est où ce plan économique
culturel sur ton politique je pense que
les équatrines d'ailleurs qui fait qui a
fait un très bon travail
d'identification des besoins de
discussion elle a auditionné poids de
150 personnes c'est pas plus avec une
petite équipe puisque les conseillers
territorial et puis nous avons mis un
deuxième ça c'est la réalité économique
sont les égalités comme on les règles
comment structure la personne la
question de la des personnes âgées des
jeunes du chômage des équipements du
transport des collèges des lycées de
l'éducation etc et puis nous avons aussi
mis un deuxième train sur pied qui est
l'évolution institutionnelle parce que
nous ne pouvons pas et
ignorer le besoin de compétences et de
pouvoir supplémentaire pour voir diriger
nous-mêmes la structuration du
développement local et si on a besoin de
se paramétrage qui colle veuillons à une
importance capitale on a configuration
des enjeux du développement la fiscalité
les réglementations etc on a besoin de
ça donc on a mis les deux dans un même
état je rappelle que dans mon équipe
collectivité territoire j'ai pas que des
gens ppm ça veut dire partie
progressisme on a des gens de
diverses tendances
il faut tenir compte de ça donc nous
avons mis ce train-là et nous voulons
monsieur le Président et puis qu'on a
dit que donc il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin
profiter de cette fenêtre qui risque de
s'ouvrir je me fais mettre ça avec la
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est l'opportunité
d'une réforme de la Constitution quand
je dis ça on n'est pas sûr et certain
c'est pas ça dépend du président de la
République principalement mais des
enjeux on nous montre bien tous les
juristes sont d'accord là-dessus qu'il y
a un enjeu considérable qui risque de se
présenter c'est une occasion nous nous
préparons comme vous fait d'ailleurs ici
aussi nous nous préparons à être prêt et
j'ai souhaité que ce soit dans un cadre
institutionnel le Congrès puisque nous
avons congrès contrairement à d'autres
régions qui n'ont pas bon nous avons
donc Congrès a été ouvert pour que ce
soit légal pour que ce soit pas une
revendication
isolée bon ça légal donc je suis dans le
canal institutionnel monsieur le
Président donc l'État doit savoir ça je
suis dans mon initiative politique nous
sommes des politiques l'appel de Paul
parce que politique
et nous avons tout de suite en juin deux
mois ouais organiser des choses pour
qu'on puisse être dans un cadrage
institutionnel pour ne pas laisser de
chance à qui que ce soit de ne pas
négocier
parce que soit on négocie politiquement
soit à négocie institut Macron a décidé
le président a décidé de négocier les
deux à la fois l'appel de France et je
le remercie mais aussi les réponses
peuvent par rapport à notre congrès
parce que le Congrès c'est pas les
chimie le Congrès c'est tout le monde je
n'ai aucun pouvoir sinon celui qui
initie mais sur le pouvoir des élus du
peuple martiniquais qui dit rentrons
dans une négociation
c'est une négociation c'est pas une
discussion c'est pas je t'aime moi non
plus c'est c'est une négociation donc
nous posons le cadre de la négociation
puisque c'est nous qui sommes en
initiative et nous discutons à ce moment
ce sera l'état de nous dire ou non pour
quelle raison parce que je pense que la
réforme de la Constitution doit se
construire de manière hyper moderne moi
j'ai vécu toute ma vie au côté d'un
homme qui a fini aussi qui nous a
clairement donné à la ligne
c'est le droit d'initiative par la
différenciation communautariste soit pas
dans ça enfermés mais le respect de
notre identité dont notre personnalités
collectives de notre dignité et notre
capacité à faire autre chose autrement
on laisse ce pays-là et au gré des
instances budgétaires de l'État sans
corpus sans et racines s'en fondation
d'une nouvelle émergence qui pourrait et
faciliter de fixer ou que les jeunes
peuvent rester parce que les jeunes
quittent les pays et ça monte on disait
qu'il y a que la Martinique qui font
dans le dépérissement démographique dont
le déplacement social dont le
desperissement tout court du peuple
martiniquais ça commence à se sentir à
la Réunion ça commence à se sentir tu
veux partout donc nous sommes dans cette
trajectoire le calendrier c'est que nous
allons d'ici
et le 6 de ce après avoir une deuxième
un troisième congrès parce qu'on a déjà
fait deux congrès troisième congrès ce
sera ce seront les propositions qui
seront issues du diagnostic de quelqu'un
de cocon et de l'équipe qu'il a aidé
ensuite nous allons passer en décembre
au résolution à discuter à présenter
avec la avec le gouvernement
attend sur le vol institutionnel que sur
le web purement développé avec lui il y
a deux rendez-vous le prix le
rendez-vous du somme à la fin du mois de
mars le rendez-vous du somme n'est pas
l'aboutissement et la conclusion de
discussion ce ne sont que des ce n'est
qu'un rendez-vous pouvoir et accepter ou
refuser tous ceux qui est de l'ordre
social de l'économie des infrastructures
de la santé de ce qu'on veut c'est le
sium bon et bien la deuxième rendez-vous
c'est juin juillet c'est ce sont les
propositions d'évolution
institutionnelle c'est pour ça que j'ai
très ravi je suis venu physiquement
moi-même pour pouvoir répondre à vos
questions parce que pour moi il faut
absolument qu'il y ait une dynamique je
rencontre cette affaire d'après-midi la
présidente de l'Assemblée
des députés et je pense franchement
qu'il faut qu'on l'ensemble
une personne qui qui ont la charge qui
ont la responsabilité puissent conjuguer
ensemble réforme pour qu'on trouve la
meilleure formulation vous avez bien vu
que je vais pas rentrer dans la
rédaction par rédaction vous avez
peut-être me poser des questions dessus
73 74 j'ai voulu rester à niveau
purement politique pour vous dire que
nous comptons sur le Sénat vraiment nous
comptons sur l'assemblée et on est assez
déterminé
on a bien sûr l'obligation si sinon
la responsabilité d'être d'interroger et
surtout de faire la population participe
activement nous sommes pratiquement une
centaine de réunions que nous organisons
dans les quartiers dans les communes
pour sensibiliser les gens à cet enjeu
là aussi et ça se passe très bien les
acteurs économiques nous faisons venir
des spécialistes en Martinique pour
présenter les enjeux qui sont à la fois
institutionnels constitutionnelles ou
économique je pense à soukramayen qui a
fait une intervention il y a pas
longtemps qui d'ailleurs dans
l'Association des juristes
et nous avons fait venir aussi des
investisseurs pour avoir une
clarification on a fait venir Thierry
vidéo c'est ça qui qui a fait une
intervention extrêmement importante à
Martinique et nous allons faire parler
des agriculteurs des pêcheurs etc je
pense qu'il faut franchement ouvrir des
perspectives c'est notre dernière chance
autrement tous ceux qu'on n'aura pas et
on aura laissé comme
on s'en occupe pas avec ça ce sera
récupéré par par une revendication plus
identitaire qu'autre chose ce qui est
aussi un combat qui est noble qu'il faut
regarder avec une incompréhension d'un
côté l'état de l'autre côté des élus en
enclume et le peuple et chaque fois
qu'il y aura malheur de type covid et
bien vous allez avoir la résistance la
résurgence de violence extrême de plus
en plus violent et moi je souhaite pas
qu'on en arrive là d'ailleurs pour ça
que je me suis engagé aussi pour toi
merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le Président vous avez
déjà embrassé un certain nombre de
questions mais on va revenir
tranquillement avec nos collègues
notamment au travers de ces
interrogations il y en a une moi qui me
taraude un peu mais je pense que vous
l'aborderai notamment Catherine au
travers des des consultations qui ont
été menées c'est lequel le regard vous
portez sur le l'accompagnement de l'État
sur les politiques publiques sur sur vos
territoires sur votre territoire en
l'occurrence
et est-ce que pour vous la
déconcentration a permis suffisamment
justement d'assurer ce rôle territorial
et est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
également dans le regard que l'État doit
mener sur le pilotage des politiques
publiques qu'il mène sur nos territoires
et sur votre territoire en particulier
moi il faudrait
supprimer le par l'individu mais le rôle
et la fonction c'est le préfet
donc il faut arrêter avec ça il faut
mettre un représentant des affaires
régaliennes de l'État
et de telle sorte que
je suis un autonomie mais et donne la
République je suis pas un autonomie
séparatiste donc il faut supprimer sur
le préfet il faut remplacer ce préfet
par par ici plus à peu près fait mais
chargé des grands intérêts des grands
sujets et régaliens de l'État parler de
l'armée de la monnaie de la justice etc
et bien sûr du droit c'est à dire que ce
que nous faisons nous martiniquais ou
bien au peuple sur nous faisons soit
reste dans le cadre du droit de la
République voilà c'est tout ça tout ce
qui concerne le développement interne et
local collectivité
point clair avec une dimension droit à
l'initiative liée à la possibilité
d'adapter ou d'initier les lois dans des
compétences qui nous sont accordées
énergie
urbanisme aménagement etc c'est sûr que
j'appelle la responsabilisation parce
que je n'ose pas différenciation après
responsabilisation la responsabilisation
à mon avis va conforter et l'enjeu de la
présence de la démocratie parce que vous
regardez faites une analyse des courbes
de participation aux élections
on parle tous les records outre-mer faut
pas franchement il faut se poser la
question mais pourquoi c'est très
distant si elle préfère qui décide c'est
pareil qui décide c'est le ministre vous
voulez faire n'importe quoi il faut
demander l'autorisation à YZ en plus le
ministre qui connaît pas grand chose
souvent pas tout le temps mais il est
pas il connaît pas revu il est très
gentil à limite j'ai souvent rencontré
des ministres mais qu'est-ce que tu
penses comment faire et que faire je
comprends bon mais donc on a supprimé
les préfets bon voilà pas les éliminer
je parle de
tout le monde a compris la nuance
monsieur le Président
c'est un contrôle à mon avis être ça va
restituer des pouvoirs et des
responsabilités aux élus locaux au corps
ce sera pas facile au début ce sera
compliqué mais ça va nous permettre de
construire aussi de l'ingénierie locale
parce que il n'y a pas de culture
outre-mer dans les ministères comme ça
ça existe vous allez je rencontre des
gens dans les ministères qui sont
devenus des amis ministère de la Ville
ou autre qui sont mais c'est pas
africain il y a pas une culture un
réflexe et j'en parlerai je parle
culture on s'est compliqués on avait
besoin de ramer toute la journée etc
donc pour la première chose c'est ça la
déconcentration des pouvoirs c'est pas
une bonne chose si vous déconcentrez des
pouvoirs vous décentralisez les pouvoirs
dans les mêmes mains
parce que déconcentré c'est une chose
c'est de l'organisation administrative
technique de la mise en oeuvre la
décentralisation de pouvoir politique
donc à mon avis il faut conjuguer les
deux décentraliser déconcentrer dans les
mains des élus
et qui sont contrôlés systématiquement
parce qu'il y a à la fois les risques
mais aussi des erreurs qui peuvent être
réalisés bon si jamais bon je pense
qu'il faut absolument conjuguer les
décentraliser dans les mains
de l'élu quelquefois c'est on parle de
décentralisation de compétences et
déconcentrer les moyens dans les mains
du buffet vous avez créé un binôme il
suffit que deux mecs de femmes c'est
foutu donc ça a pas de sens si vous
déconcentrez des décentralisé des
politiques moi et des consulats
administrativement
ce sont les feux européens je vous
rappelle François et et le ministre
héros jean-marco et il avait lancé à
cette époque là et l'appel à candidature
je sais pas quels sont les régions qui
veulent s' trouver des fois il m'a dit
oui tout de suite
en trois mois on l'avait déjà fait notre
réponse bouclée mais c'est une avancée
considérable là vous avez l'idée le
projet et le financement avant de sortir
le baratin classique vous n'avez pas de
technicité on nous finance même on nous
donne de l'argent pour avoir la
technicité mais c'est normal tous les
mecs les jeunes qui sont formés
jusqu'à là jusqu'au bac y compris à l'UA
quand vous faites le coup le jeune
devant un beau jeune et devant moi et
deux jeunes et devant moi et quand vous
voyez le coude de ces gens-là on a
dépensé 100 400 600000 euros de
formation ça a coûté
etc et puis le mec part il s'en va il a
rencontré une doudou à Paris ou c'est
l'inverse il fait ses enfants il vit en
France mais c'est fini donc c'est
il faut qu'on ait un lieu de d'exercice
de l'ingénierie mais on n'a pas
l'exercice de générique donc ça il faut
arrêter ça troisième chose c'est que je
pense que si on fait ça on redonne du
sens à la démocratie et aux élections et
à toi on aura une partie beaucoup plus
forte parce que c'est beaucoup plus
intégré ça va construire parce que
construit une législation locale de
l'action et exécuter l'action monsieur
le Président nous sommes que des
exécutants vous entendez je sais que
donc soit d'accord on est des exécutants
et on nous le rappelle ça dépend du
préfet bon on ne le rappelle très
souvent vous êtes des exécutants ceux
qui ont les vrais pouvoirs et sur le
plan normatif des États-Unis c'est la
DAE l'OMF et puis la classe
c'est pas les individu parce qu'ils sont
hyper gentils ils sont très sympas
d'ailleurs les mecs ils sont hyper pas
de problème de personne c'est que vous
avez c'est pas la question du contrôle
de nature la qualité de la
réglementation mais vous êtes
complètement pris en tenaille par
rapport à des logiques qui sont
indépassables donc pour moi c'est ça et
aujourd'hui je le dis comme je le pense
je pense honnêtement que c'est pas
rendre un service à ces raisons à ces
collectivités pour pouvoir être autant
tutélisé par l'État sur le plan local on
me dira alors bien passé au 74 mais cela
c'est le débat le plus ridicule que j'ai
jamais vu d'ailleurs pour avoir droit à
l'initiative il faut perdre les
capacités régaliennes de l'égalité bon
parce que après je 64 jours mais c'est
pas le choix des Martinique si je parle
74 comme ça monsieur rejeté dans toutes
les consultations c'est d'ailleurs ça
s'est vu mais à mon avis il y a et
je suis pas du tout satisfait des
mécanismes maintenant
on réussit quand même à fonctionner mais
mais ça c'est à mon avis ça nous permet
pas d'atteindre des objectifs que nous
souhaitons
merci de cette réponse très clairement
il y a un propos que j'aime beaucoup
d'ailleurs c'est une réflexion qui a été
qui a été on fera le tour de table après
victoire il y a aucun problème ne
t'inquiète pas on a un peu de temps à
consacrer à cette audition on s'est mis
d'accord c'est effectivement l'absence
ou l'incapacité de l'État central à
avoir un regard sur la politique qui
serait le mener dans nos outre-mer et
quel que soit la couleur politique
d'ailleurs des gouvernements et comme
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président on peut comprendre que
l'éloignement effectivement depuis Paris
peut compliquer cette cette tâche là et
parce qu'il y a une absence de culture
vraisemblablement ici ce regard là il
n'existe pas aujourd'hui il faut pouvoir
changer de paradigme changement de
paradigme peut être ce que vous évoquez
sur la gestion sur nos territoires des
politiques publiques qui concernent nos
territoires et la partie régalienne qui
relève effectivement de la puissance de
l'État ce qui permet vraisemblablement
peut-être d'inverser les regards puis
d'inverser surtout la manière dont les
compétences sont exercées
on va continuer sur le volet un peu plus
constitutionnel parce que vous avez déjà
embrassé largement les relations et puis
je pense que nos collègues ont envie de
vous poser des questions donc on
laissera aussi ce temps nécessaire on va
aller sur le volet constitutionnel et je
laisse la parole à Micheline merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues le 12
juillet 2022 vous avez des carrés que la
Constitution française doit offrir à
chacun de nos pays bien plus que le
choix sommaire et binaire entre
l'Arctique 73 et 74 quel est votre avis
sur une éventuelle fusion ou réécriture
des articles 73 et 74 de la Constitution
ouvrant la voie à des statues sur mesure
et la fin de la dichotomie d'hommes
comme quelle garde fou devrait y figurer
compte tenu de votre vision de l'avenir
institutionnel de la Martinique
et merci beaucoup pour cette question la
je pense que la France
nous devons tout faire pour aider notre
pays la France
a évolué dans la question de la prise en
compte de la subsidiarité
il y a une panne d'applications qui est
un grand principe européen qui est non
appliqué clairement au niveau national
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
décentralisation plus plus plus plus
plus parce qu'on a d'assez principe on a
du mal donc
la deuxième chose c'est que
il y a un enjeu
post-colonial et un enjeu post
départementalisation parce qu'il faut le
dire clairement nous sommes dans une
période de poste départementalisation
qui est en train de naître quoi parce
que le bienfait parce qu'il faut pas
dire que le départementalisation n'a
rien apporté je suis pas d'accord
là-dessus le bienfait de la
départementalisation est un processus
qui a montré ses limites quand je dis on
écoute mais on rentre dans une période
de poste départementalisation où on est
un peu gêné aux entourner ça au niveau
le tour 59 mais au-dessus de l'artiste
73 69 c'est pour l'Europe sur les bonnes
applications les politiques publiques
donc la différenciation intrinsèque à la
construction de la loi du droit primaire
et non pas simplement l'adaptation me
semble assez considérable
j'ai analysé en détail le statut des
Açores des études madères et des
canailles
et quand on voit la rédaction du droit
primaire et du droit constitutionnel
portugais espagnol de ces pays-là on
voit bien que c'est à l'intérieur même
du système ça a été construit un
partenariat de construction législative
réglementaire qui courbore des
politiques de développement public on
sait que c'est d'abord la loi et ensuite
la construction se fait sur le terrain
donc la France pendant longtemps y
compris après 2003 mais même s'il y a
des évolutions sérieuses qui ont été
faites de différenciation des statuts ou
des fonctionnement on a quand le veineux
un glissement entre la spécialité
législative et l'identité législative
il y avait c'était l'identité
chez vous là
il dit la raison il y a un glissement
avant c'était la priorité c'était
l'identité législative tout le monde
cherche à ça maintenant les gens
recherchent une spécialité législative
quand on prend l'exemple de ce matin a
réussi parfaitement à entrer dans
intégrer un processus de spécialité
négatif sans appel abandonné réellement
l'identité législative d'ailleurs ça
m'entête à la fois et oui mais souhaite
d'ailleurs de venir péter un bon on voit
bien que ça commence à devenir un peu
compliqué et que c'est à la cave qu'on
trouvera des solutions alors la question
que vous me posez est-ce qu'il faut
rester dans l'opposition binaire en 73
74 ce que je ne veux pas clairement dit
dans mon interview mais quelle est le
résultat
il y a peut-être deux hypothèses que je
vois comme ça que la première petite dit
bon ben écoutez on supprime ces des
articles et ont cru quelque chose de
nouveau qui permet d'avoir pas la loi
organique curseur d'évolution ça c'est
possible c'est une discussion
homologicienne c'est Bertile c'est ce
qu'on a rien qui propose pas les
juristes et puis politique il y a pas
mal il y a aussi la possibilité de
d'avoir une rédaction des articles 73 74
parce que vous avez déjà des gens qui
considèrent qui a des acquis dans
l'article 74 veulent pas reculer et
d'ailleurs c'est Martin très clair
là-dessus ils veulent pas reculer ils
ont parfaitement raison donc la
rédaction de ces deux articles pourrait
permettre d'avoir l'instauration par la
Constitution au titre de l'artiste 73
d'un vrai pouvoir d'initiative locale
par le pouvoir normatif que Monsieur
Macron a rappelé lors d'une intervention
il y a combien de temps après trois mois
l'intelligence collective montrant bien
de manière unanime tout le monde dit la
même chose qu'on peut pas continuer
comme ça il faudrait trouver la chose la
plus intelligente qui soit acceptable
par les populations notamment pour
chaque population donc on est à la
limite condamné à l'hiver du forumage
par structure par pays quand vous voyez
la Guyane qui est qui a la taille de
l'Autriche après ce que j'ai comme
surface qui a tous les moyens de d'une
indépendance ça la revendication du à
l'aise et légitimement différent de la
revendication Martin
donc en attendant les conclusions de
votre congrès vous avez déjà annoncé
qu'il y avait deux réunions qui
s'étaient déroulées avez-vous quelques
pistes institutionnelles d'orientation
qui se serait dégagée
il y a eu uneanimité
il y a uneanimité à la fois les
signataires de la pôle développement de
France mais aussi des élus locaux
avec des postures différentes mais il
faut pas assez dans ce truc mais vous
aimez bien que
la pluralité des élus que nous avons
c'est nous devons respecter le
cheminement qui va nous conduire à des
résolutions c'est comme ça ça s'appelle
ça s'appelle nos lois dans le texte de
juillet qui est configuré les
compétences
l'organisation de ces collectivités et à
ce moment on pourra vous dire que ce
succès que ça décide à ceux qui me
concernent personnellement je l'ai
exprimé très clairement je suis vraiment
pour un pouvoir d'initiative structure
tout le pouvoir normatif domicilié de
manière pérenne
réglementaire initiative localement
adapté un texte sur de l'assemblée et la
collectivité peut saisir ce texte dans
les 30 jours un mois je sais pas quoi
pour l'adapter au réaliser local et puis
il y a des initiatives que nous pouvons
prendre il faut trouver le processus
pour que ce soit bien cadré parce qu'on
est quand même la République on n'est
pas indépendant mais voilà donc je suis
vraiment pour une large responsabilité
voire une au niveau d'autonomie
acceptable
justement on va dire de responsabilité
quel serait la limite entre la notion de
responsabilité et la notion d'autonomie
alors c'est un c'est une question très
importante
on a une société qui est très fragilisée
vraiment hyper fragile donc pour moi la
question de la responsabilité est liée à
la question de l'autonomie pour moi de
l'autonomie n'est qu'un cadre c'est pas
c'est un petit peu comme c'est pas une
thèse c'est pas une cathédrale quoi
c'est pas une doctrine fermée il faut
être dedans il faut pas bouger il faut
avoir tel truc je pense qu'il y a des
degrés d'autonomie qui se qui sont
différents la seule chose c'est qu'il
faut quand même qu'il y ait un socle
minima et c'est plutôt le minima de
l'autonomie qui m'intéresse que le
substrat ou le plus d'autonomie le
minimal d'autonomie c'est le pouvoir
locatif si on n'a pas le pouvoir
normatif local pour réglementer et
adapter il y a aucune espèce d'idées
d'autonomie et envoie-moi de
responsabilisation ou de responsables
encore moins d'autonomie donc il faut
absolument que ce soit clair la deuxième
chose c'est que il faut que qu'on puisse
construire une nouvelle démocratie
économique ça c'est une condition
extrêmement importante parce que
autrement quand j'ai eu une démocratie
économique c'est la possibilité d'accès
compte tenu de l'histoire qui a freiné
une grande partie de la population dans
sa dynamique d'émancipation simplement
par l'esclavage de la colonisation il y
a un dispositif à mettre sur pied pour
permettre à toute chacun d'avoir accès
au terre accès à l'immobilier en
entreprise accès aux financement etc
faut pas nier que il y a une partie de
gens qui naissent avec les 4000 hectares
et puis il y en a qui naissent avec deux
mètres carrés quoi bon je caricature
mais c'est exactement ça et c'est tous
ce processus qui va nous permettre
d'être beaucoup plus efficace en matière
de politique publique transport logement
assainissement sanitaire etc moi je veux
la responsabilité je ne supporte pas
qu'on me dise que l'État va régler le
problème de l'eau pour moi
je ne supporte pas ça ne serait-ce que
dire ça ça m'exaspère un problème aussi
primaire élémentaire si vous avez pas
capable de régler le problème de l'eau
dans votre pays c'est pas la peine
démissionner quoi bon donc pour moi
c'est un bon exemple je règle le
problème de
nous-même bon et puis après bien sûr on
se fait dans les cas des règlements
sanitaires européennes bien sûr tout ça
c'est ok mais ne me dites pas on est
dans cette infantilisation là mais on
est dit oui vous pouvez pas le faire
j'ai dit vous vous avez organisé le
notaire chez moi
puisque mon ingénierie a disparu parce
que les jeunes partent vous voyez il y a
une boucle qui s'est créée qui fait que
aujourd'hui on peut de mon point de vue
répondre très clairement à cela voilà
vous avez excusez-moi madame et
rapporteur je voudrais tout simplement
m'excuser je ne voulais pas prendre la
parole pour poser une question mais
comme je suis venu je vois merci
monsieur le Président de la CTM comme
j'ai une autre réunion je voudrais quand
même Messenger au lieu de partir
j'étais très cher et que tu
là pour notre oui mais j'ai écouté
essentiel et de toute façon on va
travailler de toute façon merci beaucoup
et je suis désolé d'avoir été rempli le
cours de votre réunion c'est très
intéressant mais j'ai une autre
impérative mais c'est important merci
alors vous avez dit que la population
était fragilisée vous avez parlé aussi
des
traumatismes du passé que je peux
comprendre justement comment
adhèrent-elles à cette perspective
d'évolution institutionnelle est-ce que
cela suscite des espoirs des inquiétudes
et honnête il y a une
forte distanciation de la population par
rapport aux enjeux de l'évolution
sexuelle vous parlez de
l'enjeu local ça va capter beaucoup plus
la population sur les problématiques
intéressantes à la population mais à la
limite c'est légitime et normal c'est
logique quand vous parlez d'évolution
institutionnelle c'est c'est pas l'enjeu
c'est pas c'est pas important mais c'est
en train de changer petit à petit on
sent à travers la population une volonté
de changement
être et européen et dans l'Europe
l'Union se pose pas de problème mais
c'est conçu comme ça et c'est accepté au
fait un sondage les gens être dans la
République et se dire français je pense
que les différents choix des
Martiniquais je parle de martiniquais je
veux pas mêler des affaires Guadeloupe
et autres on sent que
c'est pas de mec des gens vont voter
l'indépendance
être caribéen ça commence vraiment à
être perçu et ressenti puissamment être
martiniquais encore mieux et être dans
l'Amérique dans un bassin américain ça
se ressent de mieux en mieux pour des
raisons très spécifiques qui sont liés à
l'histoire ils sont donc on a
actuellement un besoin de convaincre la
population c'est pour ça qu'on a pris le
terrain pragmatique des réponses à
apporter à la population c'est le
travail de Catherine moi j'ai pris le
chemin de répondre concrètement je suis
sur l'eau comme
ça quoi mais pas que l'eau quoi les
routes le transport parce que il faut
pas dissocier les besoins immédiats de
la population les besoins en perspective
mais nous sommes des politiques nous
sommes des élus donc c'est à nous aussi
de prendre tous les risques
pour dire il faut absolument qu'il y ait
cette évolution constitutionnelle que la
Constitution soit modifiée est-ce que la
population soit consultée ou simplement
une réunion qui se fera lors du congrès
ça c'est le choix du président de la
République mais postérieurement à la
position pour changer de statut des
règles sont très claires dans 13 sur 72
c'est qu'il faut consulter la population
donc si on prépare pas une bonne
consultation de la population vous aurez
un échec adapté à terme et je ne veux
pas de ça mais je ce que je ressens ça
prend quoi les gens commencent à
s'intéresser à ça
c'était le sens de ma question vous avez
beaucoup parlé de mon pays vous parlez
de la Martinique et justement la
l'écriture proposée dans le livre de
Michel Magra sur la le rapport sur la
différence territoriale
parle de cette notion de pays
d'outre-mer que êtes-vous favorable à
cette réécriture à cette
institutionnalisation par nom de ce
terme de pays
des mots qui sont liés à l'embarras de
notre embarras outre-mer nos différents
pays avec la France c'est c'est DOM-TOM
Drôme enfin un peu la poche un séjour je
me retrouvais comme le nom d'une fusée
qui s'en va pour moi ça a pas de sens du
tout au contraire c'est infantilisant
c'est mécanique c'est même humiliant tu
es d'où vient tuer ce site au miel donc
il faut trouver un moyen pour ça la
deuxième chose c'est que je pense
honnêtement il faut simplement appeler
ces pays par leur nom Martinique moi je
suis martiniquais point je suis pas
dommier moi je suis Martinique ça va
être la Réunion etc ça c'est mal je vous
parle en position personnelle donc je
pense qu'il y aura des résolutions
là-dessus aussi
la je pense aussi que
il faut vraiment considérer ces pays
comme les pays c'est pas des pays
indépendants ce sont pas des nations
états ce sont des cultures et des
nations des identités qui soient et dont
les résilience dépendent de la force et
de la puissance de leur culture et ce
qui me ferait le plus c'est que on est
un délit essence en train de perdre les
racines de nos cultures il faut remettre
ça non pas de manière folkloïste parce
qu'il y en a qui sont pour le doudouisme
pas moins donc il faut remettre ça à
l'eau du deuxième chose je pense qu'il
faut absolument et ça c'est notre combat
que la notion de peuple sera reconnue et
bien sur la constitution jusqu'à présent
de l'imparfait puisque nous reconnaît
que les populations d'outre-mer et non
pas les peuples voomers mais je pense
que dans les temps qui viennent ça
devrait évoluer vers cela et puis la
dernière chose je pense que ces
identités dans leur pluralité
multiculturelle configure
la France de demain je le ressens plus
profond de nous
vous avez cette représentation déjà bien
implantée dans en France notamment
toutes les grandes villes les plus
particulièrement dans les dans les
banlieues de Paris nous avons ce besoin
d'exposition multiculturelle quand je
parle de multiculturelle au sens pur du
terme c'est à dire avec une identité
propre non pas fermée sur soi-même mais
qui irrigue les autres identités dans la
diversité je pense qu'on est entré dans
l'entrée dans un processus qui fait des
dégâts aujourd'hui dans les rapports que
nous avons et notamment et avec le
racisme qui reste larvé qu'on le veuille
ou non mais ça ça se construit
plaisir que je vais dans certains
instances en France je vois des gens de
toute origine de toute nature comment ça
se mélanger ça va prendre du temps parce
que la colonisation est l'esclavage des
limbique c'est difficile y compris pour
les colonisateurs d'hier des effacer ça
bon donc il faut laisser le temps en
temps constituer que construire pour
qu'on se brossage l'outre-mer c'est le
paramétrage l'organisation la
préfiguration du monde de demain tu as
sa pluralité telle que ça a été conçu et
vécu par Césaire Césaire n'a pas
emprunté la philosophie des Lumières
pour se faire plaisir théoriquement aux
politiquesment il a emprunté parce que
c'était le cheminement de l'humanisation
et de la liberté c'est ce qui là qui l'a
fait qu'il a adopté très tôt en 46 et
pas en analyser les 60 au moment des
indépendances il a fait le choix d'être
dans un ensemble mais il a pas fait le
choix de la simulation de l'aliénation
il a fait le choix aussi d'existence en
tant que population un peuple donc c'est
c'est ce combat complexe et je pense
aujourd'hui que au Sénat avec l'impact
que nous avons avec la présence de
beaucoup de vous même y compris des gens
originaires de d'ici qui qui défendent
ces idées là qui sont nés ici mais dans
la plupart des pays on va émerger une
capacité intellectuelle de créativité de
création et notamment je vous rappelle
une phrase je dis mais attention on a
pas de mine on n'a pas d'or on n'a pas
de pétrole on n'a pas de gaz on a
peut-être découvert du gaz bientôt et
chez nous et qu'est-ce qui peut nous
aider à sortir il me dit le désastre du
climat va certainement nous offrir des
possibilités de reconstruction du monde
et ne perdez pas du tout cette occasion
là de se saisir de la reconstruction du
monde parce qu'on a les bases et des
moyens de le faire parce qu'on n'est pas
encore arrivé à l'optimum du capitalisme
traditionnel c'était sa phrase bon oui
je pense qu'on a la nature qui se
modifie aujourd'hui on peut construire
de nouveaux modèles de développement
plus approprié à nos réalité
je terminerai par une dernière question
que pensez-vous d'une manière générale
de la proposition de réécriture du
rapport de Michel Magra
alors pour moi j'ai lu avec attention le
rapport c'est la copie que tu m'as donné
que tu m'avais remise
il y a un deuxième rapport qui est sorti
récemment 2020
en 2020 effectivement 2022 c'était la
rencontre avec les juristes de la jeedom
aux élus sous tout ça j'ai lu cette
rencontre avec la jeedom je suis
vraiment que ça a été très bien
retranscrit et le rapport de ma grâce se
situe d'un continuité de ces deux
mouvements là c'est ça que je suis en
train de toujours lui dire que le Sénat
fait un super boulot la semaine devrait
copier
je pense que
il faut vraiment qu'on puisse trouver
les bases nécessaires d'analyse à
travers ces rapports-là y compris sur
une Maga qu'il faut certainement aller
beaucoup plus loin que ce qu'il a fait
pour essayer de transcrire
dans le droit constitutionnel mais aussi
dans les lois
normatifs notamment la loi organique et
puis les lois ordinaires les process je
trouve qu'on va pas assez loin parce que
il y a quand même un enjeu autour de
l'organique là c'est la loi organique
qui va configurer le degré de niveau
d'autonomie mais la logique est
postérieuse
je pense honnêtement qu'il faut inverser
ça comment j'en sais rien je suis pas
juriste je connais pas mais il faut
trouver un processus pour que pour la
population soit transparente c'est pas
seulement un changement 73 64 64 75 je
sais rien mais c'est vraiment un projet
de société et ce projet soit décliné
dans la loi organique donnant les moyens
pour atteindre ce but de projet de
société de cadrage est clair et ça va
nous obliger de répondre à ces enjeux-là
pays peuple ou autre économie et
économie primaire de plantation
importation aussi pour atteindre par
exemple l'autonomie alimentaire
qu'est-ce qu'on doit avoir comme pouvoir
est-ce qu'on peut agir sur certains
paramètres à quel moment c'est l'État
qui intervient par exemple le droit
foncier le doigt foncier je pense que
c'est il faut laisser ça à l'état pour
régler les problèmes avec nous avec une
part de responsabilité parce que il y a
pas que obtenir des pouvoirs normatifs
partager des pouvoirs c'est ça la
complexité qu'on doit avoir à ce
moment-là et si on veut la loi organique
à mon avis doit être beaucoup plus clair
en amont savoir à quoi correspondra la
l'organique la Martinique choisira si la
Martinique choisit d'évoluer c'est ça
qui nous gêne et puis deuxièmement il
faut à mon avis inversé la mentalité de
l'État qui consiste à dire démontrer que
vous êtes bloqué pour pour qu'on puisse
vous ouvrir la porte vous entendez ça
cette phrase pour moi est grave c'est
pas déjà qui dit ça comme ça mais je le
traduit comme ça démontrer que vous êtes
bloqué je suis en train de souffrir dans
une maison j'ai pas d'eau j'ai pas
d'électricité je touche
démontrer que vous allez mourir pour que
je puisse vous ouvrir la porte pour
expliquer parce que attention c'est un
petit peu ça que que Emmanuel Macron a
été extrêmement clair moi j'ai reprises
dans la République l'intervention qu'il
fait c'est dans ce cadeau là maintenant
vous trouvez face au ministère le
ministère vous dit bon ben
n'a pas dit ça clairement mais on sent à
travers les écrits que faites la
démonstration elle a dit je aime l'a dit
à plusieurs reprises que tel article
n'est pas adaptable tel article n'est
pas tel décrire
bon on fait une démonstration faut dire
clairement ça et à ce moment on verra si
on fera et si nécessaire j'ai dit si on
discute avec moi on me dit si nécessaire
je quitte la table
il y a pas si nécessaire alors si
nécessaire on va modifier non il y a un
acte politique quand même franchement
pour toi quand on a l'amendement qui a
été et le racisme en France ou certaines
grands amendements comme et Madame
veille sur cesser des grands moments de
la vie politique on prend un acte
politique et puis c'est un acte
politique la suppression de la peine de
mort vous avez vu quelqu'un vous a dit
si nécessaire non on a des enjeux
majeurs et l'outre-mer attention
quand vous cumulez le tout on est à 2-3
millions d'habitants c'est pas n'importe
quoi et c'est une présence et une
puissance géopolitique géostratégique
pour la France qui fait que la France en
deuxième rang mondial maritime
monsieur le parlementaires est très
amicalement j'ai demandé à l'ofd c'est
bien ça B de bien vouloir évaluer et le
la valeur écologique des services que
nous rendons ils ont vu qu'il me boulait
me tourner en rond j'ai exigé ça ils
n'ont jusqu'à présent j'ai pas ça encore
il y a une petite étude qui a été faite
approche qui a été faite par l'UCM et
une petite étude qui a été faite par la
Martinique on évalue notre contribution
écologique dans le marché carbone à 80 à
100 millions d'euros pour la Martinique
j'ai jamais vu ça moi cet argent là
cette contribution écologique que nous
avons mais ça où
à quel moment on me dit monsieur vous
votre zone je suis pas égoïste moi je
suis pas en train de dire que le
languedoc-roussi on apporte rien du tout
c'est pas ça du tout mais je pense qu'il
faut absolument et comme ça dernière
chose je pense aussi qu'il faut
absolument
dans le processus de réparation et de
construction il faut qu'on soit clair
entre nous on va dénommer des noms de
rouille en Martinique il faut ce qu'on
peut pas garder des noms je suis pas
d'accord avec le radicalisme tout le
monde le sait mais il y a quand même des
choses qu'il faut des renommer parce que
les personnes ont porté des des
histoires et des moments très très
graves en termes de crime contre
l'humanité bon ok mais il faut qu'on
soit très clair
je ne comprends pas que le ministère de
l'Outre-mer soit toujours à la rue du
Nord
le 27 août du 9 c'était le ministère des
Colonies
les archives des crimes de la colonie se
trouve toujours au sous-sol là où il
nous
comment on peut garder là où Dino comme
lieu de discussion de dialogue
démocratique de respect de l'homme dans
un contexte historique contre le connaît
je pense qu'il faut absolument déplacer
le ministère d'outre-mer ailleurs ne me
dites pas que l'État n'a pas de bâtiment
il faut déplacer là où Dino ça peut pas
être le ministère du Robert autrement ça
reste un ministère des colonies de
l'esprit de tout le monde voilà voilà ce
genre de choses là qui pourrait
construire des réparations
merci monsieur le Président je vous
propose de passer maintenant la parole à
nos collègues qui j'en suis sûr on vit
vous interpeller donc la parole circule
dans la salle pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président bonjour merci de partager avec
nous
toutes ces réflexions et vos positions
moi je suis sénateur de Polynésie donc
je connais bien effectivement l'article
74 et l'autonomie
et je suis d'accord avec vous sur
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
une question que nous vivons nous
effectivement c'est cette question de
l'égalité et vous avez eu raison
d'insister sur le sujet
parce qu'on a l'impression alors ça en
faire l'histoire de la construction de
l'autonomie polynésienne que l'autonomie
a pu être accordée mais force est
constater que ça se fait aussi au
détriment de l'égalité
et avec ce double discours permanent qui
est de dire que la Polynésie c'est la
France mais vous êtes autonome donc vous
devez assumer
et cette et je pense que cette
dualité doit faire partie de nos
réflexions collectives
parce que vous avez raison il n'est pas
normal dès lors que nous sommes citoyens
français tous
que l'on nous oppose systématiquement
cette volonté de subsidiarité
d'autonomie de gestion
au plus près de nos populations alors
pour nous à 16000 km de Paris mais quel
que soit le nombre de milliers de
kilomètres c'est la même le même sujet
et en même temps de nous comment dire de
nous projeter dans une espèce de de
bulles qui serait coupé du reste de la
République ou en tout cas dans nos
maîtrisons pas les limites sur le plan
de l'égalité
[Musique]
ceci posément la question de l'autonomie
fiscale
qui est en fait ce qui est clivant
aujourd'hui et je serais intéressé de
savoir quel est votre position sur le
sujet puisque nous avons effectivement
nous la capacité de lever nos impôts et
donc déroger en totalement au système
fiscal national
et à l'inverse est-ce que Bercy de
manière plus ou moins claire en fonction
des époques
nous oppose lorsque l'on demande à ce
que l'État puisse participer à
l'exercice des compétences polynésiennes
disons mais vous ne cotisez pas au pot
commun donc pourquoi voulez-vous de la
redistribution
ce qui donne finalement une notion
financière de la citoyenneté française
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une forme de
comptabilité qui devrait être tirée à la
fois de ce que on rapporterait entre
guillemets à l'état et de ce qui ce à
quoi on aurait droit en échange de ce
que l'on rapporterait alors bien souvent
nous avons été mis finances quelques
années en Polynésie j'ai pu poser la
question mais combien rapporte la et son
préjudice si mes collègues sont là de la
Corrèze ou de je ne sais quel Ardèche
quelques régions que ce soit à Paris et
combien elle reçoivent en retour parce
que pourquoi est-ce qu'à chaque fois les
outre-mer doit avoir cette espèce de
comptabilité équilibrée et ce que l'on
ne fait pas forcément avec les régions
métropolitaines enfin c'est un sujet de
fond et en tout cas parmi les réflexions
que nous avons sur les évolutions
institutionnelles c'est vrai que nous
nous sommes arrivés très loin dans
l'autonomie alors contrairement à la
Calédonie nous n'avons pas encore la
capacité de voter des lois au sens
législatif du terme puisque nos axes
sont réglementaires même si elles
s'appellent loi de pays
il y a quelques donc
point précis sur lequel nous souhaitons
avancer mais moi je pense que le point
et vous l'avez indiqué central c'est
cette question de effectivement de
l'autonomie mais de l'égalité on ne peut
pas avoir une double lecture non plus de
la citoyenneté française et ça
m'intéressait d'avoir vos réflexions sur
le sujet il me semble que il n'est pas
juste que nous ayons une forme de
comptabilité qui nous soit qui est une
gestion comptable de la citoyenneté
ultra outre-mer quelle qu'elle soit
voilà et je vous rejoins nous nous
appelons pas les tomiens ou les comiens
nous sommes Polynésiens et français
effectivement et je crois que ça doit
s'appliquer à chacun de nos territoires
oui Président
c'est toujours un plaisir et à l'intérêt
d'écouter Serge il provoque la
maïeutique avec sa vision globale des
Outre-mer avec
ce côté cash et
avec cet esprit de
d'analyse
profonde qui même si on n'est pas
d'accord avec tout ce qu'il dit
ça suscite la réflexion et aujourd'hui
on n'a pas perdu notre notre matinée
effectivement moi aussi je suis d'accord
avec pas mal de choses que tu as que tu
as développé
[Musique]
on est arrivé au bout
c'est vrai
cependant si l'on s'arrête juste au
niveau des dômes
il y en a quatre qui sont départements
depuis 76 ans
il y en a un qui ne département que
depuis 11 ans
les quatre
ont eu une région et un département à
part un tiers et sont passés à la
collectivité unique nous à Mayotte nous
n'avons jamais eu de région nous n'avons
jamais eu de départements et en quelques
années nous avons basculé de
collectivités
d'outre-mer à département région
d'outre-mer
région qui jusqu'à présent je suis
désolé de le dire mais nous ne sommes
pas en Paris de cette dimension
régionale et tout en partageant les les
analyses
que fait-on que fait-on parce que
au niveau de Mayotte je suis obligé de
faire un comparatif il est plus question
de clarification de ce qui a été voté
par référendum en 2009 en train en
vigueur en 2011 de précision notamment
de cet aspect régional parce que nous
sommes départements région mais par
exemple nous avons un nombre d'élus de
départements 26 sur une population qui
qui est au delà de 300 000 habitants et
nous continuons à voter à élire les
représentants de la collectivité au
moins au mode départemental c'est à dire
que
il y a 13 listes 13 projets cantonaux
et c'est une fois qu'on a élu les élus
du département
qu'il faut réfléchir à un projet commun
alors que
la logique voudrait que
nous ayons un mode de scrutin régional
pour avoir un projet global et que les
électeurs avant d'aller
devant devant les urnes mais sache quel
projet pour Mayotte il choisirait donc
je te remercie parce que tu es
développements permettent de clarifier
cela moi je t'inviterai
je demande à tout le monde à ton
homologue de Mayotte Benissa vraiment
peut-être de d'organiser un coloc de
t'inviter et d'inviter d'autres à venir
échanger sur ces sujets qui sont hyper
hyper important
parce que quand il n'y a pas
suffisamment de précision et de clarté
comme tu viens de le faire mais la
population prend peur
nous comme tu l'as précisé l'autonomie
on ne veut même pas n'entendre parler
l'autonomie en restant dans la
République mais quand les projets quand
les orientations ne sont pas
suffisamment
précises et bien ça fait peur à la
population et du coup il y a un rejet
global style le projet de loi Mayotte
alors que là-dedans il y avait du bon du
bon aussi donc vraiment merci pour ces
éclairages ses précisions parce que ça
permet de de poursuivre de poursuivre la
réflexion pour résumer nous c'est comme
si nous avions pris un raccourci
[Musique]
pour être
au même niveau que les autres les autres
Dom mais ce raccourcir encore faut-il
que l'on se donne les moyens qu'on nous
donne les moyens de l'emprunter parce
que s'il y a un raccourci et qu'on ne
sait pas qu'il a un raccourci et bien
son empreinte pas son on emprunte un
chemin un chemin qui qui nous perd et
pour finir peut-être sur une question
dans le prolongement de la question du
président Artano quand tu as répondu à
l'accompagnement de l'État tu as dit
quelque chose
encore une fois de très juste que je
tiens rappeler c'est qu'il n'y a pas
dans les ministères de réflexe
ultramarin
et quand tu ajoutes à ça c'est ma
question mais vous voyez où je veux
aller vers la réponse quand tu ajoutes à
ça que le ministre dédié le ministère
dédié le ministère des Outre-mer qui est
dédié à nos territoires et bien ne gère
que 10% des budgets de ce territoire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait donc est-ce que en plus de la
disparition des préfets ou plutôt le
remplacement des préfets pour un
représentant régalien
est-ce que la persistance du ministère
des outre-merdes dans ces conditions là
a du sens
répondre d'abord et puis après redonner
la parole à la salle ça permettra de
donner un peu de respiration aussi à
notre audition alors ce que disait
Emmanuel Macron je le rappelle discours
du Château-Gontier le 10 octobre et il
parlait de vrais décentralisation s'ils
sont ces expressions que je reprends je
avec trois éléments extrêmement
importants transférer des compétences
transférer le mode de financement et il
ajoute c'est là il a vraiment raison et
transféré le pouvoir normatif et donc la
responsabilité donc les trois sont liés
pour l'instant pouvoir le motif on y
était pas donc on rentre dans une
nouvelle ère pourquoi pas du revivre et
puis alors écoute je partage totalement
ton point de vue totalement la question
de l'autonomie qui se construit au
détriment de l'égalité c'est c'est tout
le combat qu'on mène
parce que la et c'est le combat à mon
avis le plus intelligent le plus
réaliste le plus clair
je battais dès que je voyais Maina
salut là pour moi si jamais tu la croise
en difficulté ou nos autres copains de
Polynésie je veux rester à deux trois
heures du matin dans le missile pour les
aider
et franchement j'ai trouvé quelques fois
l'attitude l'été il y en a qui l'achève
mais quelquefois l'attitude de l'État
notamment sous la santé
de voir les Polynésiens être en posture
de demander de supplier d'avoir un
financement en plus on leur répondait
vous avez un contrat de développement
faites ce que vous avez bon après on
fait des visitait par accorder
les conséquences des essais nucléaires
en Polynésie ont été trois quatre heures
du matin en débattait pour essayer
d'obtenir les modalités d'indemnisation
bon l'égalité des doigts n'est pas
l'ennemi du droit à la différence les
deux doivent se conjuguer autrement les
rapports entre les pays d'outre-mer et
la République n'a aucun sens ça n'a
aucun sens pour me prendre son
indépendance quoi c'est tout terminé
donc si c'est beau négocier que vos
droits à l'égalité en fonction du degré
d'initiative que vous mettez en oeuvre
ne serait-ce que pour votre culture
votre légitime bon vous êtes polynésien
vous avez une vraie culture comme
Martinique et une vraie culture ça n'a
pas de sens et ça ça s'applique pas que
à tel point ça s'applique à tout c'est
possible de l'égalité donc l'accès à
l'égalité telle que ça a été conçu par
Césaire et ceux qui ont présenté vers
gestes etc c'était pas du tout
l'ignorance des particularités c'est
d'ailleurs tout le débat autour de
l'universel l'universel c'est pas le
fait d'ignorer le particulier et où la
singularité que l'universel se construit
c'est justement en intégrant le
particulier comme un élément de la
construction de l'homme qu'on dit qu'on
est dans des choix universel et la
France a loupé cette étape là c'est un
loup pas historique complètement
historique il est temps de réparer cela
et je suis totalement d'accord qu'il
faut absolument aller dans ce sens quant
à le gros débat parce qu'après la
question quel est votre choix et
d'autonomique quel type d'autonomie
quelle est votre choix fiscal bon c'est
toujours la même débat oui à la France à
la République au Sénat et à sommet
national le gouvernement je sais que
nous apportons moins en contribution
fiscale et par rapport à ce que nous
avons comme dotation bon je rappelle
quand même que la Polynésie je lise tout
à l'heure c'est l'équivalent de l'Europe
en surface maritime bon d'accord donc si
vous nous coupez ce doigt à l'égalité
vous devez aussi vous infliger la même
coupure en possession d'espace maritime
quand je dis c'est tout ce qui a
derrière écologique richesse aliotique
collectivité infrastructures logistique
y compris dans le rapport que Dieu tu as
fait et il y a un gros paramètre sur la
question de la présence militaire et de
la puissance militaire de la France bon
tout ça ça compte donc faut pas qu'on
vienne nous raconter que plus vous allez
vers la reconnaissance des droits
d'initiative locale comme ça moins vous
avez non on peut avoir un choix fiscal
qui soit assez sûr qu'on nous défendons
précisément la question je considère que
tous ceux qui fiscalité économiques doit
être décidé localement bon maintenant
tous ceux qui est fiscalité solidarité
pour appeler pour mettre un package sur
la tête dans la communauté nationale et
avec les solidarités nécessaires c'est
ça qu'il faut faire passer comme ce
qu'on va vous dire oui mais écoutez si
vous prenez ça vous levez
Saint-Martin même eu des difficultés au
début
la force va être quand même pu avoir un
moment transitoire pour la collecte des
ressources fiscales et c'est Marley est
en difficulté à monnaie parce qu'elle
avait plus pas les moyens de René sur
Normal société au niveau national parce
que ce matin une commune de la
Guadeloupe bon donc je suis
véritablement sur ta ligne il faut faire
disparaître ces édition comptable de la
citoyenneté et d'avoir une posture
respectueux des populations la seule
chose qu'il faut c'est là où on a des
compétences et qu'on doit guider le
développement économique avec l'outil
fiscal il faut qu'on puisse peser dessus
aujourd'hui on a un outil qui s'appelle
le toit de mer qui nous permet de peser
mais c'est toujours pareil c'est le même
octobre qui alimente tes finances et
collectivités territoriales communales
40% à peu près donc en gros plus vous
importez plus vous avez des recettes
fiscales il y a le primaire c'est quand
même une absurdité économique incroyable
comme outil fiscal à la fin de
valorisation de protection de nos
productions c'est quand même quelque
chose d'important donc je suis là dessus
et donc il faut d'un point de vue
puisque c'est des baladais avec la
puissance technique et juridique que
vous avez c'est à vous de Sénat de
d'étudier ça pour nous on va la faire
étudier mais bon on a pas les moyens on
peut donner à votre disposition pour
vous donner des éléments concernant
l'interruption du la oui je pense que
je voulais tout d'abord dire que le j'ai
beaucoup de d'admiration et de sympathie
pour
bénissa je le dis parce que
je te dis parce que je sais pas si tu es
en opposant ou qu'on n'est pas très bien
bon non c'est quelqu'un de remarquable
très présente pour son pays dans les
différentes instances et il est très
clair
bien entendu
il faut surtout pas dire autre chose que
ça
il défend exactement ce que tu défends
c'est-à-dire l'aboutissement de la
régionalisation départementalisation le
choix d'un processus de consultation
électorale soit adaptée locale et puis
surtout l'aboutissement par rapport aux
enjeux de configuration de l'égalité des
droits et j'espère qu'on profite toi par
rapport à notre expérience de lui dire
de ne pas lâcher du tout même si
bénéficie de l'égalité des droits sur le
paramétrage culturel identitaire de son
pays qui est Mayotte moi je vais donner
ce conseil alors donc on a je pense pas
que vous ayez fait oui c'est ça peut
s'expliquer comme c'est de raccourci
mais je pense qu'un choix j'ai vécu ce
choix là pour Mayotte avec Nicolas
Sarkozy qui dans son processus qui a
présenté sa assemblée nous étions à
assemblée donc j'ai dit c'est le choix
le Mayotte je respecte ce choix là le
choix de la population et mais il faut
absolument
que les les la dynamique même de du
respect de la parole d'État sur
l'égalité des droits se conjugue avec la
différenciation sur
Benissa m'a beaucoup parlé d'un coloc
qui aura le 8 le 9 décembre je crois
chez toi et il souhaite vraiment c'est
pour un droit des Outre-mer au 21e
siècle c'est un débat qui devait il me
demande de venir et comme j'ai du mal à
lui refuser quoi que ce soit donc je
sais pas mais je vais pas me gagner tout
de suite mais j'aurai de l'agenda pour
voir si je peux venir sur place répondre
à quelques questions
salut
Serge est toujours
j'ai dit au fait de ces questions là
puisque chaque fois on t'écoute sur la
question de l'évolution sociale de la
transformation des territoires c'est
toujours avec plaisir alors je voudrais
dans le prolongement de la question de
Dany en tout cas de la réflexion de Tani
sur je disais ça comme ça sur la
maquette aussi budgétaire des Outre-mer
aujourd'hui on a dit c'est 10% de tout
ce que nous
deux milliards 8
1 milliard un milliard de milliard 8 et
even 2 millions donc à peu près 10% et
donc on y passe pratiquement du temps à
discuter sur deux lignes sans même toi
conditions outre-mer emploi
outre-mer alors que ça ne change dans le
paradigme
rien du tout puisque les évolutions sont
des évolutions 1% de pour cent sans que
nous puissions connaître exactement dans
le cadre de cette différenciation des
territoires au préalable quels sont les
projets des territoires qui soient je
dis à la limite
pas très clair donc dans l'élan de la de
ces évolutions là à mon avis on parle
peu de la question du financement je
parle pas du financement local du
financement que tu as bien précisé
acté ou le plus que ce qu'on voit
au niveau national ce que nous recevons
n'est pas négligeable est-ce que ce ne
serait pas aussi le moment dans cet élan
de revisiter la maquette budgétaire
des outre-mer pour qu'il y ait déjà dans
la maquette technique qui est pas de
ligne qui est une maquette avec un
budget des Outre-mer avec l'ensemble des
lignes qui soit au préalable déjà
fléchés
voilà ça on est dans la danse là il a
voulu dire aussi à mon avis à travers
ses écrits sur cela
c'est un frein
ça pourrait
décomplexifié vidéo
dans la tête même des des des des
territoires puisque on reste toujours
avec
tuer plus en avant si tu es 74 tu es
plus en arrière si tu es 73 tu vas trop
loin si tu 74 tu vas passer loin bref il
nous faut trouver des moyens pour sortir
de cette dichotomie définitivement
d'accord on ne parle pas de 74 ou 73 on
est dans un champ
chez chacun va une boîte à tiroir chacun
prend ce qu'il souhaite à son rythme
dans un seul article puisqu'il faut il
faut codifier cette partie là pour
éviter puisque tant qu'on restera
puisque c'est Martin est en 74 à
défendre européens citron retrouve plus
et et chaque fois qu'on aborde les
questions d'évolution institutionnelle
sur ces articles c'est un frein à la
population parce que ce ne sont que ceux
qui maîtrisent le droit constitutionnel
qui en parle à mon avis c'est un
ne pas effrayer la population on peut
pas parler de quel article pour moi
c'est donc trouver un moyen pour qu'on
ne parle pas d'actifs d'articles où on
parle de besoin on parle de chemin on
parle de développement et puis ça
tombera la ce sera dans le petit
l'article unique numéro 1 voler deux
volets trois bref qu'on n'est pas ça je
pense que si on veut participer pourquoi
je dis ça quel que soit les réunions
d'appel le Fort de France
des élus on l'a vu en 2003 chez nous
uneanimité des élus il faut passer par
la case
de la population et à mon avis autant où
ça marche très bien l'appel de
Fort-de-France il dit les travaux sont
en cours les réunions
si la population
n'est pas je vais dire en phase et n'est
même pas sur le point même d'une
revendication on va encore le rater donc
il faut que ça devienne pratiquement une
revendication de la population avec des
choses simples qu'est-ce que puisque
quand on entend je veux dire les
émissions rien ne marche
ok donc le peuple réclame du changement
et donc après quand on offre le
changement par le haut le plus petit
Vous allez vous voulez aller trop loin
donc il faut que ça soit une
revendications donc on je pense quoi
qu'à partir de l'appel de France
construit l'argumentaire
pour que ça soit je dis à la disposition
de la population donc voilà un petit peu
une proposition de de maquette de
revisité la maquette budgétaire mais une
proposition aussi de de populariser la
fin de la dichotomie 73 74
ce président ah oui
en fait je vais pas je vais pas grand
chose à rajouter puisque ce débat qu'on
a chez nous de manière récurrente quasi
quotidienne je suis impliquée dans la
démarche donc j'ai pas grand chose à
rajouter
on a une véritable révolution culturelle
à créer dans nos propres têtes parce que
on nous a pas enseigné le champ des
possibles on y restreint on ne croit pas
que ce qu'on puisse faire on a des
doutes sur nos capacités et une espèce
d'absence de confiance permanente de
tous ces et quand on dit aux gens mais
on pourra il y a des choses qu'on ne
peut pas faire aujourd'hui et qui seront
possibles une espèce de peur et très sec
de cette
dû à cette espèce de tutelle y compris
intellectuelle dans laquelle nous sommes
depuis des décennies pour ne pas dire
des siècles donc c'est l'occasion d'une
véritable révolution culturelle de
l'oxygène qui qui doit être apportée
dans dans le débat politique et ça c'est
un vrai challenge je prends le cas de
l'éducation je suis désolé il faut qu'on
soit plus appliqué dans dans les
processus d'éducation on peut pas
continuer à vomir chaque année enfin au
fait d'aller scolaire de la
discolarisation de l'échec scolaire
25% des gamins qui rentrent en 6e qui
ont des problèmes de lecture on peut pas
continuer avec ce système et puis
attendre simplement qu'à chaque fois
recto-vienne avec sa petite méthode
passe deux ans disparaissent reviennent
un nouveau qui arrive il faut tout
reprendre à zéro chacun arrive avec sa
déontologie et le système continue
continue de nourrir de l'exclusion la
culture c'est fondamental la vie vivable
donc si on a on n'attaque pas au fond
par exemple cette politique publique et
qu'on la prenne à notre compte qui est
une manière d'enseigner chez nous il y a
une manière de parler aux élèves il y a
des rythmes scolaires à réserver on
n'est pas des mathématiques à 14h en
Martinique quand il fait plus de 30
degrés il y a il faut de l'école ouverte
il faut d'autres manières d'enseigner il
faut que le créole soit intégré dans nos
dans notre pédagogie et ça c'est quelque
chose qui doit être domicilié chez nous
on ne peut pas être secouer à chaque
fois par le bon vouloir d'un lecteur qui
arrive qui est pose ses règles des
règles qui qui n'a pas le temps ni la
culture ni de les comprendre ni de les
mettre au goût du jour et ça c'est
extrêmement important parce qu'on est en
train de de crier un terreau de de
difficulté quant aux apprentissages
quand à l'éducation qui enseigne mais
qui pas du tout qui continue de charrier
son lot d'exclusion et et ça c'est une
vraie vraie vraie préoccupation en plus
dans un dans un numéro scolaire qui
n'arrête pas de baisser là aussi on est
passé sous la barre des 70 000 élèves
scolarisées ça continue c'est environ -
700 - 800 élèves chaque année dans
l'académie avec des exclusions par
territoire
on est moins favorisé quand on est dans
le Nord alors que entre entre le Lorrain
et Fort-de-France c'est 45 minutes de
route c'est rien et pourquoi là comme ça
là on a encore c'est c'est tranche
d'exclusion qui font que par exemple le
nord de la Martinique c'est la partie la
plus la plus la plus désolée c'est la
partie la plus compliquée c'est
quasiment tous les établissements
scolaires qui sont plus alors qu'on est
à 45 minutes de du centre et de la
capitale donc il y a problème il y a un
vrai problème et c'est pas réacteur qui
va gérer ça je suis désolé c'est pas un
acteur
président merci monsieur le Président
est-ce que mon ami Théophile a indiqué
sur la digue de Tommy mais aussi avant
ça il a parlé du financement c'est un
véritable enjeu Facebook
parce que la
là on
l'a collé une très mauvaise image sur la
gestion des collectivités territoires du
jambon
qui a beaucoup de collectivités qui sont
en situation de visiteur en difficulté
etc je le dis en résumé si les
collectivités de la c'est notamment les
communes et pas servi de SAS sous le
plan social et la Martinique serait pas
relu déjà 350 000 habitants en
Martinique serait peut-être à 250 000
habitants donc c'est pas
clientélisme politique et les retards
structurels de ces pays par rapport à
l'autre au niveau national
c'est quand même clairement affiché
depuis 60 ans c'est moins 40%
d'investissement public et des retards
en matière de politique de logement
d'habiter insalubre c'est véritablement
des une bidonvilisation qui a construit
30% de l'urbain des différentes communes
de Guy à Saint-Denis à Basse-Terre
Pointe-à-Pitre donc la pauvreté la
misère des années 45 ans 60 prennent
double d'électricité le retard a été
considérable parce que c'était une
colonie qui brusquement a basculé on lui
a attribué les paramétrages de mesures
économétrique
qui sont le pays qui n'ont pas connu la
même histoire
donc on a un enjeu de financement
plus de mauvais gestionnaire en
Martinique ou ailleurs qu'ici il y a une
des structuelle que nous connaissons et
qui qui a plombé l'évolution de notre
pays deuxième chose c'est que
il y a un paramétrage justement et que
le financier sur les dotations de d'État
qui commence à un petit peu l'état
commence à prendre conscience à
renforcer ses voies financiers pendant
très longtemps la le soutien des
collectivités était lié à l'adhésion
politique des élus pendant très
longtemps par mois j'ai pas vécu ça mais
mes aînés ont parfaitement vécu ça je
pense qu'il faut une révision assez
complète et sur le plan de la
nomenclature budgétaire et financière et
je prends un exemple précis nous avons à
la collectivité territoire de Martinique
une absence presque totale d'autonomie
fiscale
les recettes c'est un milliard d'euros à
peu près les recettes
l'autonomie fiscale que nous avons c'est
toujours de 200 millions d'euros
c'est à dire
on a aucune autonomie
c'est-à-dire la décision d'orienter ou
te fait évoluer la fiscalité nous
n'avons pas donc c'est extrêmement
faible la deuxième chose c'est que
95% des recettes sont prêts affectées
donc quelle est la marge que vous avez
90% sont pris affectés quelle est la
marge que vous avez de réorienter alors
que c'est d'affectation comptable et
obligatoire donc il y a un vrai travail
à faire troisième exemple on répète trop
long
l'entretien des routes
des bordures de route fleurissement
aménagement etc c'est inscrit en
fonctionnement
nous c'est 60 millions d'euros de
dépenses liés à l'entretien des bordures
de route traitement d'espace vert etc
mais chez nous c'est une richesse
écologique ça pose trois fois quatre
fois plus vite que sous les bords de
haute et là où il y a l'hiver il y a
plusieurs types de climats ça pousse
extrêmement vite c'est-à-dire qu'on a un
surco lié à l'entretien qui n'a rien à
voir ici il suffirait de passer
l'entretien des routes fleurissements
entretien et que en investissement qu'on
économise en fonctionnement 60%. c'est
que pour elle nous permet d'améliorer
notre retour financement et notre
capacité de faire face à un débat donc
on a vraiment un travail colossala faire
c'est pas seulement venir réparer à
travers des outils d'État pour
cadrer la la chambra des comptes devrait
aussi en plus du travail avec la chambre
fée qui est un bon travail de contrôle
devrait se pencher sur les problèmes
structurés de ces collectivités pour
établir un peu le financement quand je
parle le premier fiscal je suis très
sérieux c'est-à-dire vous avez de
l'argent c'est déjà pré-infecté vous
n'êtes que n'exécuteur budgétaire
de l'orientation de préféchage et comme
l'État a transformé tout le paramétrage
fiscalité qui pouvait donner une tenue
fiscale y compris la taxe d'habitation
et bien qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien
aujourd'hui c'est transformé dotation
donc vous êtes soumis à vous au budget
de l'État aux orientations aux maigreur
ou grosse qualité des budgets de l'État
donc nous avons besoin d'une réforme et
je pense que tu as raison de soulever ce
problème parce que c'est concomitant à
négocier avec lesquels il va falloir
qu'on pose ce problème là et y compris
l'avenir de colmer et des financements
des collectivités territoires sur la
question de 73 74 on en a beaucoup parlé
il faut qu'on sorte de cette dichotomie
et c'est l'intérêt raison tout à l'heure
a bien montré par l'expérience de la
Polynésie qu'il y a un vrai drame
d'une présence citoyenne de ces
différents pays au sein de la République
avec ce chantage là qui est fait
sur le pont d'égalité Catherine donc qui
connaît bien tous ces sujets là
sur l'exemple qu'elle donne c'est un
très bon exemple c'est l'éducation
quelle est la compétence à la bonne
exercice sous compétences et pouvoir
quelle est la compétence de que nous
avons nous avons une compétence nous
occuper des bâtiments
des trois lettres de l'entrée la
propreté le câblage
réparer les
feuilles de toile qui pourrissent
on nous a donné comme compétence
alors vous dites je n'ai pas de
compétences ou l'angle pédagogique
sauf les conventions que je puisse
signer avec le rector ou la lecteur qui
arrive à tous les deux trois ans sur tel
dispositif je vous rappelle on fermait
une école dans le nord de la Martinique
c'était Saint-Pierre parce qu'il y a pas
assez d'élèves il y a très peu on est
passé de 600 élèves 80 élèves donc le
proxénique c'est pas celle qui est là et
elle a décidé et puis elle m'informe
j'ai pu mon téléphone pour
rouspéter donc j'ai pas fait seulement
on peut pas faire des écoles parce que
c'est bien va mourir bon et me dit mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on en fasse
je dis bah oui vous inventez quelque
chose pour le futur et le niveau on fera
une école du numérique du design du
numérique
et bien elle a fini par accepter écoutez
bien c'est elle qui a accepté c'est pas
le ministre c'est pas moi donc je lui ai
proposé ça a été très gentil vous voyez
c'est une république on ne compte sur la
bonne ou mauvaise humeur des individus
bon est très sympa de si vous voulez
d'accueil on a mis les moyens vous savez
combien d'élèves on est passé de 86 ans
il y a 6 500 600 élèves dans le lycée de
Saint-Pierre qui s'occupe du design du
numérique des jeunes qui viennent de la
Martinique entière mais qui viennent de
Sainte-Lucie qui viennent d'Haïti etc on
fait une coopération voilà mais je n'ai
aucune compétence sur le plan ce qu'elle
disait pédagogique je ne peux pas de
droit demander par un règlement que je
prends en conservation qu'il t'a parce
que c'est je m'étais que c'est un
pouvoir régalien d'État je vais pas
remettre en cause simplement tous ceux
qui concerne la pédagogie active
d'éveillement de prise de conscience de
connaissances de son milieu on pourrait
eux faire des propositions pédagogiques
et deuxièmement construire les outils
pédagogiques non
bon voilà on est comme ça donc je n'ai
pas le pouvoir
réglementer au lit statut de dire que je
modifie tel type de paramétrage je
propose de religieux à discuter avec
l'État et on je fais voter avec un vide
d'État on inverse l'inversion bon et
deuxièmement sur la biodiversité on
pourrait parfaitement faire des outils
incroyables pour permettre
aux Martiniquais que je suis de me
réconcilier avec la toumo le les autres
plantes médicinales qui sont que ma
grand-mère connaissait très bien on
préfère attendre que une fille
pharmaceutique internationale Vienne
point de richesse biologique à Balata au
mont le rouge ou dans les forêts de la
Guyane au de la Guadeloupe et puis en
faire un médicament me le renvoyer par
sous forme de cachet quoi bon c'est
tranquille quoi mais vraiment quand ce
que quand je vois ce genre là aussi
incroyable quand l'État puisse ne pas la
nuit je veux pas c'est à nous fallait
que les gueuler quoi il faut être
beaucoup plus courageux de dire on
refuse c'est pour ça que j'ai envoyé le
thème négociation nous sommes en
négociation on n'est pas en discussion
bon donc ça c'est insupportable la
musique est là
oui j'ai conventionné on discute on peut
c'est pas obligé c'est pas un processus
qui est indiqué comme un acte
obligatoire de passage inscrit c'est en
fonction du directeur de directrice du
proviseur etc le créole
bon il y a un débat national où les
langues régionales ne sont pas encore
des langues inclusives d'éducation et
probable considéré comme une langue
auprès des défenses nous avons une
langue que le français je le dis
publiquement pour que personne ne me
prête d'intention mais on a une deuxième
langue à côté c'est une deuxième langue
c'est pas pas trois c'est construit en
croise c'est mal de de faire aussi des
cours en créole pour les enfants qui
sont en situation sexuelles etc donc ça
c'est je voulais quand même prendre deux
ou trois exemples que vous avez cité
d'ailleurs dans plusieurs rapports c'est
les noms
alors là franchement vous pouvez faire
l'arbre dessus
tout est normal
mais on est à 8000 km vous imaginez à
matière de base Matéo etc construction
technologique technique les normes
peuvent être nécessairement différents
si je veux construire au milieu
climatique je conçois pas bioclimatique
comme je penses-tu dans les Ardennes
bioclimatiques les Ardennes à un truc
bioclimatique mais moi j'ai un truc
différent donc la réglement
plus le ministère de logement
règlement un règlement on croit
règlement déstabilise la République
c'est quand même incroyable ça alors
quel pouvoir on n'a pas de pouvoir
combler l'éducation on a pas de pouvoir
on a une compétence en me dis on a une
compétence logement ok j'ai bien compris
que
d'exécuter alors j'exécute parce que on
fait du pli du LS du LLTS du etc des
formats de financement d'opération le
nom correspond à un format de
financement ça correspond pas à une
culture
ça y est le LLTA c'est plus financé en
subvention que le péage ou le pays etc
enfin ce sont des classiques
donc nous avons la compétence
d'organiser la construction on n'a pas
la compétence le pouvoir d'agir sur la
réglementation de la politique du
logement si vous devez changer le
paramétrage du Pmax du prix maximum de
la construction ou du loyer maximum de
logement il faut remonter à Paris
mais on fait une démonstration mais
quelqu'un qui entend ça en Martinique il
savait pas ça quand j'explique ça vous
avez 100 personnes oui mais je savais
pas ça du tout il faut que le Guadeloupe
ou le Martiniquais remonte à Paris pour
changer un paramètre thermique
en quoi ça insulte le Sénat et là et
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement
que le paramétrage technique se fasse
localement j'ai un exemple précis j'ai
obtenu par habitation vous savez on le
fait que 1100 km². donc il allait mettre
là qui plantait le banane et qui ont
transmuait leur niveau d'investissement
dans l'énergie donc il mettait c'est en
2010 quand on est arrivé à la région il
veut être des panneaux photovoltaïques
sur toutes les terres agricoles c'est à
l'aise au lieu de planter on fait le
soleil donner de l'argent et comme le
type est né avec des terrains qu'on lui
a donné et les autres sont nés avec des
cases mais il loue ce terrain par le
photographique on est tout pour nous pas
deux photos pour tout le monde en
français bon
on a du interdire par une habilitation
j'ai obtenu en trois années interdire la
réalisation des panneaux photovoltaïques
sous les terres agricoles qui ne
pouvaient plus produire ni cannibale et
encore moins ce que je souhaite c'est à
dire la diversification
nous sommes dans le ridicule est
vraiment dans quelque chose de médiocre
faute de courage et de clarté vis-à-vis
des pays d'outre-mer ce qu'on appelle la
législation capable et la réglementation
capable de structurer un développement
et beaucoup de responsables voilà voilà
cet exemple là sur on a une compétence
mais pas de pouvoir on pourrait prendre
et pour terminer la question de la santé
la question de la santé c'est ton
pouvoir également j'ai pas besoin de
contester ça mais qui peut être partagé
parce que les déserts modico du Nord en
Martinique mais c'est tellement chez toi
il y en a les jeunes qui parlent faire
des études qu'on paye et qui ne
reviennent pas les médecins comment
conventionne avec ces gens-là la
recherche en maladie tropicales
notamment certaines maladies liées
environnementales qui sont importantes à
mettre excité etc vous avez tout un pan
de la recherche notamment liée aux
moustiques
à la lutte antibactérienne qui peut être
domicilié responsabilisé et qui pourrait
permettre de faire éclore une ingénierie
de la recherche du développement capable
d'attirer du monde c'est c'est très
important parce qu'on en est dans le
bassin de 40 millions de personnes pour
la Caraïbe et si on prend l'Amérique du
Sud on prend l'exemple que du Brésil
c'est
280 millions d'habitants à deux heures
de vol
à deux heures de vol vous imaginez bien
que les enjeux qui sont liés à la
modélisation ou des modèles ou encore
des critères de noms peuvent être conçus
localement et c'est valable pour la
Réunion pour l'Afrique du Sud Madagascar
on pourrait conjuguer on m'a dit que la
réunion commence à exporter ces déchets
vers des pays tiers et d'ailleurs il y a
une réglementation qui risque de sortir
de remettre ça en cause mais ça c'est
c'est pareil pour nous tout ce qu'on
peut exporter aller dans la zone et
construit des unités et des filiales de
développement de récupération en termes
d'économie circulaire des déchets
essentiels dernière chose c'est la
coopération
alors là c'est c'est un monde on a
aucune espèce de pouvoir matière de
coopération la loi que j'ai présentée
qui a été votée à l'unanimité sera
appliqué par la Martinique mais c'est
une loi à mon avis qui ouvre une porte
d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron avait même
mis dans son programme qu'il devait
faire évoluer la chimie sur la
diplomatie territoriale mais c'est une
manière de dire qu'on peut dialoguer et
discuter avec Sainte-Lucie là on a une
circulation d'armes à feu incroyable
combinée à la drogue la Martinique est
devenue
une pseudo de passoire de drogue et
d'armes d'ailleurs les les morts les
comptes 24 morts dont a priori
pratiquement 20 à 21 par balle
ça veut dire qu'il faut discuter avec
les voisins on peut pas discuter avec
les voisins c'est l'ambassadeur le
ministère des Affaires étrangère etc et
on est que des additifs à une discussion
de données non je pense qu'on peut
co-construire des politiques de sécurité
de pêche etc voilà monsieur le Président
les réponses que je vais apporter je
sais qu'il y a il faut qu'on y aille bon
avant et bien ça tombe ça tombe ça tombe
plutôt bien monsieur le Président
puisque le timing est totalement
respecté merci en tout cas de la grande
qualité de vos propos et puis de cette
vision très claire sur l'association des
populations et pour faire écho à ce que
disait être omnité Dominique Théophile
moi j'ai toujours la faiblesse de penser
que le politique est là pour donner une
trajectoire et emmener nos populations
vers et donner du sens à l'action
publique nos administrations sont là
également pour trouver les outils
derrière et je crois que c'est bien
comme ça qu'il faut également concevoir
une évolution institutionnelle donnée un
sens à l'action publique une direction à
nos territoires respectifs la
construction juridique derrière
effectivement peut ne pas intéresser les
élus d'ailleurs qui parfois ne sont pas
des techniciens mais en tout cas quand
on a du sens dans le sens est porté de
la manière dont charger Timmy le fait je
n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que les
mouvements se font et la bascule
culturelle qui évoquait Catherine
Concorde mettra du temps se mettre en
place mais en tout cas c'est le
mouvement créé qui suscite de l'intérêt
de l'espoir en tout cas merci beaucoup
pour cette grande qualité et merci à mes
collègues je lève cette audition merci
président merci beaucoup
[Musique]